ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING
IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA OUR QUE
HAN BERMAN. BIGELOW BLOOM
BURNER **** BATH BONTA BRO
BURKE. CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU TEN DAVID CHIU
CHOI KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALY DEEP EIGHT MEN
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL. GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON.
GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY GRAYSON.
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE KILEY
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY. MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS RADIUS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TEAM
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS
WOULD MISTER SPEAKER
. MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND. FOR
THIS MORNING'S PRAYER. THE PARA
BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN REVEREND PATTY A
RABBIT REVEREND BOB STEP.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION. I REMEMBER WELL
WHEN OUR FAMILY CELEBRATED MY
DAD'S BIRTHDAY SIXTIETH
BIRTHDAY IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
TWO. IT WAS ALMOST IN PASSING
THAT HE SHARED WITH ME THAT MEN
IN OUR FAMILY DO NOT LIVE MUCH
PAST SIXTY IT WAS SO WITH HIS
FATHER AND HIS UNCLE'S. WHEN MY
DAD'S YOUNGER AND ONLY BROTHER
DIED AT FIFTY NINE. AND YEARS
LATER WHEN MY OLDER BROTHER HAD
A STROKE AND PASSED JUST EEKS
AFTER HIS FIFTIETH BIRTHDAY. MY
DAD'S WORDS SEEM PROPHETIC.
AMAZINGLY MY DAD LIVED TO BE
ALMOST EIGHTY SEVEN. WHEN WE
CELEBRATED HIS EIGHTIETH
BIRTHDAY HE TOLD ME THAT HE
FELT EVERY DAY HAS BEEN AN
UNEXPECTED BONUS. WHEN I TURN
SEVENTY LAST AUGUST I REALIZE
THAT I HAD UNCONSCIOUSLY BEEN
LIVING MY LIFE NEVER EXPECTING
TO SEE SEVENTY. AND THIS MONTH
MAKING IT TO SEVENTY ONE I NOW
FIND MYSELF UNDERSTANDING MORE
THE AMAZEMENT AND GRATITUDE
WITH WHICH MY DAD EMBRACED EACH
DAY AS HE BECAME OLDER. IF WE
LIVED THEIR ALLIES FEELING THAT
EACH DAY WAS A BONUS WE COULD
NOT HELP BUT WAKE UP EACH
MORNING JUST HAPPY TO BE ALIVE.
AND HE WOULD SLEEP EACH NIGHT
TRULY GRATEFUL FOR THE DAY.
FEELING EVERY DAY IS A BONUS
DAY CAN HELP US TO EMBRACE
EVERY DAY WITH FEELINGS OF
AMAZEMENT AND GRATITUDE. NOW
MORE ME DOWN WITH WITH KINDNESS
AND GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU EVER NOTICE THAT WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BROKE AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE.
COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THE SALUTE TO THE FLAG OF OUR
NATION PLACE YOUR HAND ON THE
HEART VETERANS MAY SALUTE READY
BEGIN. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA. THE REPUBLIC FOR
WHICH IT STANDS ONE NATION
UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO IN A ROW
YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY JULY ELEVENTH TWENTY
NINETEEN RECENTLY MET AT NINE
AM. CALDERON MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THE READING THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS
AND PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
DIRECTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGE FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. WE'LL GO TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS MISTER CALDERON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN A TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CHIU AND
EGGMAN TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. I ALSO
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GABRIEL
FRIEDMAN AND PATTERSON TO SPEAK
ON AND GERMAN MEMORY TODAY.
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RETURN THE FOLLOWING BILLS OF
THE SENATE ITEM TWENTY FIVE A.
B. SEVEN AND I'M BONTA AN ITEM
TWENTY EIGHT A. B. TEN SIXTY
ONE GIPSON. WITHOUT OBJECTION I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
ORDER H. R. FIFTY BY SPEAKER
RENDON TO THE THIRD READING
FILE. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
MOVE ITEM ONE HUNDRED SB SIX
EIGHTY WHITE HOUSE KEY TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE ITEM ONE
SIXTY NINE H. R. FIFTY ONE
WEBER FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON
.
MEMBERS OF MEMBERS ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADAM
GRAY FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JIM FRAZIER. AND FOR.
PERSONAL FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EVAN LOW
. MISS
YOU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GUESTS INTRODUCTION. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. COLLEAGUES I AM
HONORED TODAY TO HELP RECOGNIZE
AN INSTITUTION IN OUR STATE
CAPITOL AS THE CHAIR OF THE
PILOTS TO THE CAUCUS I'M HERE
TO RECOGNIZE AN INSTITUTION
THAT ALL OF US KNOW FOR THEIR
FAMOUS BANANA CREAM PIES THE
MANY EVENTS THAT ARE HELD THERE
AS WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA
HISTORY WITHIN THEIR WALLS OF
COURSE ALL OF YOU KNOW THAT I'M
REFERRING TO THE INSTITUTION
KNOWN AS- FRANK FATS
RESTAURANT. AND AS A CHAIR. AS
A CHAIR THE API LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS IT IS MY PRIVILEGE TO
HONOR THE FAT FAMILY AS WE
RECOGNIZE THEIR EIGHTIETH
ANNIVERSARY. FRANK FATS HOLDS
MANY STORIES OF OUR CAPITAL
COMMUNITY MANY POLITICAL
LUMINARIES INCLUDING EVERY
SINGLE CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR
SINCE FOR A WARRANT HAD DINED
HERE SINCE IT OPENED IN
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE. THIS
INSTITUTION WAS PART OF AN ERA
WHERE DEAL MAKING OFTEN TOOK
PLACE BETWEEN MEALS INVOLVING
LEGISLATORS AND FOLKS OUTSIDE
OF THIS BUILDING. APPS THE MOST
FAMOUS DEAL BROKERED AT FRANK
FATS WAS A LEGENDARY NAPKIN
DEAL THAT RESULTED IN TORT
REFORM. BUT MANY EOPLE DON'T
KNOW THAT BEHIND THIS VERY
SUCCESSFUL RESTAURANT IS A
STORY OF A CHINESE IMMIGRANT
WHO LACKED DOCUMENTATION WHOSE
ENCHANTED BY AMERICA'S GOLD
MOUNTAIN FRANK FAT. DESPITE THE
CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT FRANK
IMMIGRATED TO OUR COUNTRY THE
AGE OF SIXTEEN HE WAS DETAINED
AT ANGEL ISLAND IMMIGRATION
STATION AND AFTER HIS RELEASE
WORKED AS A FRUIT PICKER. A
DISHWASHER AND A WAITER UNTIL
HE RECEIVED HIS LUCKY BREAK
FROM RESTAURANT CUSTOMER. FRANK
HELD ON TO THE CUSTOMER
EARNINGS AT THE CASH EARNINGS
OF A CUSTOMER WHO HAD PURCHASED
A KINO TICKET. AND LEFT BEFORE
THE GAME BEGAN. IN APPRECIATION
OF FRANK'S HONESTY THE CUSTOMER
HELPED HIM SECURE A LOAN FOR
FRANK TO PURCHASE THE PROPERTY
AT EIGHT OO SIX ELSTREE. FATS
RESTAURANT SUCCESS WAS BORN OUT
OF HARD WORK KINDNESS AND THE
DREAMS OF AN IMMIGRANT. HIS
RESTAURANT AND HE AND HIS
FAMILY ARE SYMBOL OF OUR
AMERICAN DREAM AN ILLUSTRATION
OF THE VALUABLE CONTRIBUTIONS
OF IMMIGRANTS IN AMERICA. FRANK
FATS IS STILL A FAMILY RUN
BUSINESS TODAY WITH THREE OTHER
RESTAURANTS IN THE CATERING
BUSINESS AND THEY RECENTLY
EARNED A TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
MICHELIN RECOGNITION. AS WELL
AS A JAMES BEARD AMERICA'S
CLASSIC AWARD. ME TODAY OUR
FOUR GENERATIONS OF THE FACT
FAMILY INCLUDING THE LEADERSHIP
OF THE RESTAURANT I WANT TO ASK
ALL OF YOU TO JOIN ME. IN
HELPING TO CELEBRATE THE
EIGHTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF FRANK
FATS AND WISHING THEM SUCCESS
FOR MANY MANY DECADES TO COME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. WHERE
MEMBERS. MOVING TO BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE. THE SECOND
READING FILE ITEMS ONE THROUGH
TWENTY THE CLERK WILL READ AS
LEGAL EIGHTEEN THIRTY ONE
SENATE BILL. TWO TWENTY NINE
FOUR FIFTY FIVE TWENTY THREE
FIVE FIFTY SIX SIXTEEN SIX
TWENTY FIVE THE.
755-256-6016 FIFTY SIX SIX
SEVEN SIX SEVEN TWENTY SIX AND
SEVEN EIGHTY. ALL WE NEED READ
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MEMBERS. WE
WILL MOVE TO THE CONCURRENCE
FILE FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE AB
FOR NINETY EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR NINETY
EIGHT PRICE ONLY MEMBER WEBER
AND ACTUALLY TO BUSINESS
LICENSING DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YES GOOD MORNING
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
FOUR NINE EIGHT IS BACK FROM
THE SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS MAKE MINOR
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO ENSURE
PROPER IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
BILL THE BILL HAS RECEIVED HAD
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IT HAS NO NO
NO NO NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE AYE VOTE
ON CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WEBER SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. THE BELL RINGS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE ICE
FIFTY FOUR NEWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
BUT WE WILL PASS RETAIN AND
FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO. MOVING TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE AJ ARE
ELEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ AS
ONLY JOINT RESOLUTION ELEVEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER CARILLO AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO IMMIGRATION.
THIS CAREER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AJ ARE ELEVEN IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE SENATE AT LANGUAGE
THAT ENCOURAGES THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO PROVIDE A PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP. FOR IMMIGRANT
YOUTH AND INDIVIDUALS WITH
DEFERRED ENFORCEMENT DEPARTURE
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE EASY AND
TEMPORARY PROTECTED STATUS
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS TPS. THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
CARILLO SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. HOME MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLAIRE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
VOTE EYES FIFTY NO ZERO. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN WE
WILL PASS AND RETAIN AND FILE
ITEMS TWENTY FOUR THREE TWENTY
EIGHT MOVING TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY NINE AB ELEVEN SIXTY
EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL LEVIN SIXTY EIGHT
BY SOMETHING MEMBER MULLIN AND
OTHERS AN EXCELLENT EMERGENCY
SERVICES MR MILLING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB ELEVEN SIXTY EIGHT
WHICH REQUIRES THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES TO IMPLEMENT
A TEXT AND REAL TIME TEXT TO
NINE ONE ONE SERVICE AND ALL
COUNTIES BY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS THE MEMON
SIMPLY INCLUDE THE REQUIREMENT
THAT BOTH A TEXT MESSAGE AND
REAL TIME TECH SERVICE MUST BE
LOST BY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
ADD SENATOR STONE AS A CO OP.
THE BILL HAS MOVED THROUGH BOTH
HOUSES WITHOUT OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM THIRTY
AB THREE TWENTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE THREE
TWENTY ONE BY SOME REMEMBER
PATTERSON AND ACTUALLY TAXATION
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX
LEVY MISTER PATTERSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB THREE TWENTY
ONE IS BACK ON CONCURRENT
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
WERE MINOR AND CLARIFYING THIS
BILL IS ENJOYED OVERWHELMING
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN BOTH
HOUSES I RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER PATTERSON SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS IS THERE
TO THE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. CLERK
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY TWO NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. PASS ENTERTAINMENT FILE
ITEM THIRTY ONE FILE ITEM
THIRTY TWO EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ AS A
LEGAL FOR SIXTY SEVEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER BURNER FOR
ABOUTTHAN OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE USE OF STATE PROPERTY. THIS
BOERNER HORVATH YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED GOOD MORNING MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB FOR SIXTY
SEVEN REQUIRING EQUAL PAY A
PRICE FOR BOTH MEN AND WOMEN
WHAT FOR ATHLETIC CONTESTS ON
STATE PROPERTY IS FOR
RECREATION IS BACK IN
CONCURRENCE FROM THE SENATE.
CHANGES MADE INCLUDING INCLUDE
INCLUDING TRUCK CALTRANS IS ONE
OF THE STATE AGENCIES TO BE
REQUIRED TO MEET THE GUIDELINES
OF THIS BILL. THIS BILL DOES
ENJOYED RESOUNDING BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN BOTH THE ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND ONE EIGHTY
FOUR SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS BURNETTE HARDBACK
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE- ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS MODE YOU DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO VERY VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY NINE
KNOWS ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO THE THIRD
READING FILE FILE ITEMS SIXTY
SEVEN EIGHTY SEE A FOR THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT FOR BY
FAMILY MEMBER MULLIN AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO ELECTIONS. MR
MAILING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT A SEE A
FOR WHICH WOULD ALLOW SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLDS TO VOTE IN PRIMARY
ELECTIONS PROVIDED THAT THEY
ARE EIGHTEEN BY THE TIME OF THE
GENERAL ELECTION. ACA. FOR
WOULD CREATE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ENGAGE CALIFORNIA'S YOUNGEST
VOTER DEMOGRAPHIC AND BOOST
YOUTH PARTICIPATION IN OUR
ELECTIONS. THIS IDEA IS NOT A
NEW ONE NEARLY HALF OF STATES
LET ME SAY THAT AGAIN NEARLY
HALF OF STATES IN THE U. S.
ALREADY ALLOW SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLDS TO PARTICIPATE IN
PRIMARIES AND CAUCUSES. FIRST
TIME VOTERS SHOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN A
FULL ELECTION CYCLE. IN FACT
THIS IDEA FIRST APPEARED IN
THIS BUILDING SOME SIXTEEN
YEARS AGO. WHEN MY FATHER A
FORMER THIRTY FIVE YOUR CIVICS
TEACHER PROPOSED. AND THE
MULLENS PLURAL HAVE MADE
ADDITIONAL ATTEMPTS ON THIS
FLOOR AND IN THIS BUILDING BUT
MEMBERS THIS IS AN IDEA WHOSE
TIME HAS FINALLY COME. THIS
EFFORT IS A SIMPLE PREMISE IF
YOU ARE ALLOWED TO VOTE AS AN
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD IN THE
GENERAL ELECTION YOU SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO HELP SHAPE THE
CHOICES THAT APPEAR ON THE
GENERAL ELECTION BALLOT BY
VOTING IN THE PRIMARY. WE ARE
TREATING IT SHOULD BE TREATED
AS AN ELECTION CYCLE PRIMARY
AND GENERAL AND- WE ANCHOR THIS
EFFORT. IN YOUNG PEOPLE
BECOMING EIGHTEEN AND HOPEFULLY
HABITUAL VOTERS CALIFORNIA IS
IN THE UNUSUAL POSITION OF
PLAYING CATCH UP ON CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT. ILLINOIS INDIANA
KENTUCKY. MISSISSIPPI OHIO AND
SOUTH CAROLINA ARE JUST A
HANDFUL OF THE STATE'S WHERE
THIS IS ALREADY LAW RED STATES
BLUE STATES AND PURPLE STATES
AS CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT ACA
FOR WE GO BEFORE THE VOTERS. WE
WOULD ULTIMATELY BE GIVING THEM
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE THIS
DECISION. YET I AM FULLY
OPTIMISTIC THAT VOTERS WILL
EMBRACE THIS MODEST REFORM TO
IMPROVE CIVIC PARTICIPATION AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER MULLIN MISTER GALLAGHER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. YES THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO A CA FOR YOU KNOW
I THINK THAT. LARGELY THIS IS
BEING YOUR VEIL THAT SOMETHING
THAT HELPS EXPAND THE FRANCHISE
TO SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS BUT HAS
BEEN MOSTLY A MORE POLITICAL
ALTER YOUR MOTIVE IN THE LONG
TERM. BECAUSE IF IT WERE REALLY
TRUE. IF IT WERE REALLY TRUE
THAT WE WANTED TO EXPAND VOTING
TO CHILDREN. YOUR TO THOSE WHO
ARE MINORS THEN WHY NOT DO THE
WHOLE THING WHY NOT GO DOWN TO
THIRTEEN YEAH. ONE I HAVE FIVE
CHILDREN. WE TALK ABOUT
POLITICS A LOT. I WANNA LET ALL
MY FIVE CHILDREN YOU KNOW GO
AND GO AND VOTE. THE ONLY
REASON THAT WE'RE DOING THIS IS
BECAUSE. THE OTHER SOME DATA
THAT MAYBE SHOWS THAT SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLDS ARE GOING TO VOTE FOR
THE MAJORITY PARTY AND INCREASE
THEIR VOTE THRESHOLD IN THIS
PRIMARY DAY TO INCREASE THAT
THAT NUMBER. IN THIS CURRENT
PRIMARY I MEAN THAT'S WHAT IS
REALLY GOING ON HERE. IT LOOKED
AT THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE HAVE
SAID. THAT THE AGE OF MAJORITY
IS EIGHTEEN. AND THAT THAT IS
WHEN EVERYONE. EVERYONE CAN
VOTE WHEN THEY TURN EIGHTEEN.
AND THE ONLY PEOPLE THAT HAVE
REALLY CLOUDED THAT UP. IS THE
MAJORITY PARTY IN THIS BUILDING.
WHO WHO TELLS US THAT. YES
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS WE THINK
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO VOTE BUT
YOU'RE NOT ADULT ENOUGH TO BE
ABLE TO DECIDE WHETHER NOT TO
SMOKE. HE GOT AWAY TO YOUR
TWENTY ONE. RIGHT. YEAH YOU'RE
AN ADULT IN AT SEVENTEEN THEN
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO VOTE AND
MAKE DECISIONS. ON THE FUTURE
OF OUR DEMOCRACY. BUT IF YOU
HAPPEN TO KILL SOMEONE. THEY
COMMITTED SERIOUS OFFENSE OR
SUBMIT A SERIOUS CRIME AGAINST
SOMEBODY NO WE THINK UNTIL
YOU'RE TWENTY FIVE YOU'RE
REALLY NOT ADULT ENOUGH AND
RESPONSIBLE ENOUGH TO DO THAT
THE ONLY PEOPLE THAT HAVE
CONFUSE THIS ISSUE. IS THIS
BODY OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS.
SO EIGHTEEN HAS ALWAYS BEEN
THAT THRESHOLD IF YOU WANT TO
CHANGE OUT AND SAY NO WE
ACTUALLY THINK. THAT CHILDREN
SHOULD BE ABLE TO VOTE THEN
PROPOSE THAT. AND TAKE THAT TO
THE VOTERS AND ASK THEM IF THEY
WANT TO APPROVE THAT
CONSTITUTIONAL CHANGE BUT DON'T
PLAY THIS GAME. ON THIS FOR
ABOUT WE'RE REALLY WE REALLY
CARE ABOUT THE FRANCHISE WE
WANT ALLOW SEVEN WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLD AND A SIXTEEN YEAR OLD.
WHAT ABOUT A FRESHMAN IN HIGH
SCHOOL WHAT OUR FRESHMAN HIGH
SCHOOL THERE. THERE'S SO MUCH
MORE DIFFERENT THAN SENIORS. IN
HIGH SCHOOL. WHY ARE WE MAKING
NO RESEARCH THE I MEAN THERE
REALLY IS NO DISTINCTION THAT
YOU CAN MAKE IF YOU WANT TO
ALLOW CHILDREN TO VOTE THEN
PROPOSE THAT. BUT SERIOUSLY
LET'S NOT PLAY A GAME HERE
TODAY AND SAY THAT THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT SOMETHING THAT IS
REALLY NOT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER GALLAGHER MISTER BLOOM
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT FOR TO MY A FRIEND. OF
FROM NICHOLAS EIGHTEEN YEAR
OLDS WERE NOT ALWAYS THE
THRESHOLD FOR VOTING. THOSE OF
YOU VISITED ME IN MY OFFICE MAY
HAVE NOTICED ON MY WALL A
LETTER SIGNED BY THEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HENRY WAXMAN WHO WAS
CONGRATULATING ME AND I'M SURE.
MANY OTHERS WHO WERE GRADUATING
HIGH SCHOOL THAT YEAR AND
TURNING EIGHTEEN AND WERE IN
THE FIRST COHORT OF THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN ACCORDED THE ABILITY
TO VOTE AT THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN.
I'M AT THAT TIME THERE WERE
PREDICTIONS THAT YOU KNOW
WESTERN CIVILIZATION WAS GOING
TO FALL AND ALL KINDS OF BAD
THINGS ARE GONNA HAPPEN BECAUSE
WE WERE ALLOWING. CHILDREN TO
VOTE. YOU KNOW A REASONABLE
MINDS MAY DIFFER ABOUT PEOPLE
LIKE ME AND A WHAT'S COME THAT
BUT- BUT WESTERN CIVILIZATION
HAS NOT FALLEN AND I STRONG AND
I STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MISTER
BLOOM THIS GONZALEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU. I HAVE
OBVIOUSLY PRESENTED SIMILAR
BILLS IN THE PAST THAT ACTUALLY
REDUCE VOTING AGE TO SIXTEEN SO
THIS IS SOMETHING I BELIEVE
DEEPLY IN I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ENGAGE OUR
CHILDREN YOUNG PEOPLE CALL MY
CHILDREN CHILDREN AT TWENTY TWO
SO I CAN CALL MY SIXTEEN YEAR
OLD THE CHILD TO BUT YOUNG
PEOPLE TO BE INVOLVED WE KNOW
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE WHO VOTE THE
YOUNGER YOU ARE WHEN YOU CAST
THAT FIRST VOTE THE MORE LIKELY
YOU ARE TO BE A LIFE LONG VOTER
IT'S IMPORTANT. BUT I WOULD BE
REMISS IF I DIDN'T POINT OUT SO
I'M COMPLETELY SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS IDEA. BUT THIS. THE
SOLUTION IS NOT UNIQUE IT'S NOT
DRIVEN BY A DEMOCRATIC. IDEA IN
CALIFORNIA I COULD READ YOU THE
STATE'S BY WHICH THIS ALREADY
IS IMPLEMENTED STATES LIKE.
KENTUCKY IN MISSISSIPPI AND
NEBRASKA IN THAT GREAT.
PROGRESSIVE STATE OF WEST
VIRGINIA AND SOUTH CAROLINA IN
NORTH CAROLINA IN OHIO SO TO
SUGGEST THAT THERE'S SOME
POLITICAL PLAY GOING ON I THINK
IS DISINGENUOUS IT MAKES SENSE
THAT A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD WHO'S
GONNA TURN EIGHTEEN BY A
GENERAL ELECTION GETS TO GET
THEIR FEET WET THIS IS THE MOST
COMMON SENSE SHOULD BE EASY FOR
ALL OF US TO UNDERSTAND WHY WE
WANT THEM ENGAGED IN A PRIMARY
ELECTION BEFORE A GENERAL
ELECTION IT'S GOOD FOR THE
PROCESS IT'S GOOD FOR THEM AND
IT'S OUR WAY TO DEVELOP
LIFELONG VOTERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS GONZALEZ MISS CARILLO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. MADAM SPEAKER
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM CHICO I
REALLY. OR. FIVE CHIEF NICHOLAS
MY APOLOGIES MY COLLEAGUE FROM
EAST NICHOLAS. MENTIONING HIS
FIVE YEAR OLDS BEING ABLE TO
VOTE. THAT HAVE TO REPRESENT
THEMSELVES IN FRONT OF A COURT.
BECAUSE OF OUR FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM THAT IS
CURRENTLY BROKEN. DEMOCRACY IS
NOT A JOKE IT IS NOT SOMETHING
TO TAKE LIGHTLY. IF A FIVE YEAR
OLD HAS TO REPRESENT THEMSELVES
IN IMMIGRATION COURT YOU CANNOT
JOKE ABOUT A FIVE YEAR OLD
BEING ABLE TO VOTE. THIS IS
SOMETHING SERIOUS. THIS IS
ABOUT THE FUTURE OF OUR COUNTRY
IN THE FUTURE OF THE STATE.
NICE STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO MISTER
COOLEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
COLLEAGUES I AM VERY PLEASED TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
ON THIS ISSUE OF GROWING CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT. AND IT'S FUNNY I
FIND MYSELF THINKING OF MY ABLE
DAUGHTER IN LAW CATHERINE
COOLEY WHO. JUST COMPLETED HER
MASTERS AT USC AND SHE WAS A
CROSS COUNTRY RUNNER. AND YOU
KNOW IN CROSS COUNTRY YOU CAN
INVOLVED IN REPLACE. AND THE
ART OF RUNNING. IF YOU ARE PART
OF A TEAM RUNNING TEAM IS THE
ART OF THE BATON PASS. AND ALL
OF US IN PUBLIC LIFE. HAVE TO
CONCERN OURSELVES ON HOW IN OUR
DEMOCRACY WE PULL OFF THE BATON
PASS HOW TO THOSE OF US WHO
RISE OF PUBLIC SERVICE TO
DEVELOP A SKILL SET. WHO ARE
ENGAGED IN THE ISSUES OF THE
DAY. CULTIVATE A CULTURE WHERE
PEOPLE FEEL LIKE. THEY TOO CAN
PARTICIPATE. THERE ARE PASSED
FOR THEM THIS ORDER THE BATON
PASS WHICH IS VITAL IN A
DEMOCRACY. I THINK THE
ACCELERATED RATE OF CHANGE WAS
SHE IN THE WORLD AROUND US
TODAY. CONFRONTS PEOPLE EARLIER
STAGE WITH THAT. FORCES ARE
WORKED OR CONSEQUENTIAL IN
THEIR LIVES AND THEY DON'T KNOW
WHERE IT ALL LEADS AND I THINK
TO BE A GENERATION OF LAWMAKERS
FOLKS OF ON HOW DO WE PASS THE
BATON OF CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
INVITE GREATER PARTICIPATION.
IT IS A VERY IMPORTANT THING TO
CONSIDER. AND SO I THINK THIS
IS AN OUTSTANDING IDEA. I AND I.
SUPPORT IT AND I THINK IT IS US
AS MEMBERS EXECUTE OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO BE GOOD
RUNNERS. AND TO PASS THE BATON
A BILLION WELL TO THOSE WHO
FOLLOW US. THANK YOU MISTER
COOLEY MISS WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AS SOMEONE
WHO HAS BEEN A PARENT OF A
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD I
RESPECTFULLY URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED I AM PROUD TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AS
SOMEONE WHO WAS THE FIRST
MILLENNIAL EVER ELECTED. TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE. I
KNOW THE VALUE OF GETTING
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE YOUNG
ENGAGED AND OUR DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS AT AN EARLY AGE I VOTED
EVER SINCE I TURNED EIGHTEEN I
WAS VERY PROUD TO CAST THAT
VOTE I CONTINUE TO BE A VOTER
EVER SINCE I CAST A FIRST VOTE
AT THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN WHEN I
COULD. BUT I ONLY DID IT
BECAUSE AS I HAD A FAMILY THAT
WAS INVOLVED IN POLITICS. AND
IT WAS CONTINUE REALLY
IMPRESSED UPON ME WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT. TO BE ENGAGE IN OUR
DEMOCRACY AND I JUST THINK IT'S
A REALLY LAZY ARGUMENT. TO SEE
HERE AND SAY THAT THE ONLY
REASON WE'RE TRYING TO DO THIS.
IS BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO EARN
MORE OPEN MORE VOTERS ON OUR
SITE ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE.
BECAUSE IT COULD BE READ JUST
AS EASY. TO SAY WELL MAYBE YOU
DON'T WANT TO DO THIS. BECAUSE
YOU RECOGNIZE THAT THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF YOU
BECAUSE YOU CONTINUE TO DEVALUE
THEM. AND THEIR PARTICIPATION
IN OUR DEMOCRACY DEVALUE THEM
AND THEIR IDEAS. ABOUT WHAT
THEIR FUTURE SHOULD LOOK LIKE
WHEN WE ARE CONSTANTLY EVERY
SINGLE DAY MAKING DECISIONS
THAT ARE GOING TO IMPACT
THERE'LL THEIR LIVES. FOR ITS
ENTIRETY. SO I THINK THAT WE
NEED MORE PEOPLE VOTING MORE
PEOPLE WITH DIFFERENT IDEAS AND
I JUST DON'T THINK THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE NEGATIVE. WHEN YOU
HAVE. INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
GOING TO BEAR THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
DECISIONS THAT WE MAKE. TO HAVE
A LITTLE BIT MORE OF A SAY AND
WHAT THEIR REPRESENTATION LOW.
BECAUSE THAT MATTERS. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MR MILLING
YOU MAKE THOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR
THE DISCUSSION LET ME JUST
REMIND YOU THIS EFFORT IS ONE
THAT IS TIED LEGALLY PEGGED TO
PEOPLE BECOMING EIGHTEEN BY THE
GENERAL ELECTION SO WHEN IT IS
BEEN CHALLENGED IN OF THE
STATE'S. ON LEGAL AND
CONSTITUTIONAL GROUNDS. IT HAS
BEEN UP HELD. NEARLY HALF THE
STATES IN THIS COUNTRY THIS IS
A LAW CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO CATCH
UP ON THIS SO THANK YOU MEMBERS
ACA FOR ALSO ENJOYS SUPPORT
FROM SECRETARY SALES VIA. WHOSE
OFFICE IS IMPLEMENTED THE PRE
REGISTRATION PROGRAM WHICH
TOUCHES THIS POPULATION OF
YOUNG PEOPLE. IT'S ALSO SUPPORT
ABOUT LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
AND MANY OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
TODAY IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THOSE OF US ON THIS FLOOR TO A
POWER CALIFORNIA'S YOUNGEST
VOTERS ENCOURAGING THEM TO
BECOME LIFELONG PARTICIPANTS.
IN THE MOST FUNDAMENTAL ACT OF
DEMOCRACY MEMBERS. THE TIME HAS
COME FOR CALIFORNIA TO JOIN IN
PURSUING WITH SO MANY OTHER
STATES HAVE DONE ALLOW
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD STRIP THE
RIGHT TO VOTE IN PRIMARY
ELECTIONS PROVIDED. THEY'LL BE
EIGHTEEN BY THE GENERAL
ELECTION I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE AYE
AYES FIFTY FIVE KNOWS NINE THIS
MEASURE PASSES
. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE BACK TO
CONCURRENCE IS FILE ITEM THIRTY
THREE AB SIX OH FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY WILL SIX OH
FIVE BY SOMEONE NUMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE SPECIAL EDUCATION.
MR MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
SIX OH FIVE GUARANTEES A
STUDENT WHO REQUIRES AN
ASSISTIVE TECHNOLOGY DEVICE HAS
THE RIGHT TO USE THAT DEVICE
OUTSIDE OF SCHOOL HOURS IF
DETERMINE NECESSARY BY THEIR I
EP. AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
SENATE OR TECHNICAL AND
CLARIFYING I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. YOU MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROOM.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
VOTE I SIXTY NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR EIGHTY
SIX THIRTY THE CLERK WILL READ
AS A LEGAL SIX THIRTY BY
SOMETHING MEMBER ARAMBULA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE HEALING
ARTS MR ARAMBULA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. AB SIX
THIRTY WILL REQUIRE THERAPISTS
TO PROVIDE THEIR CLIENTS WITH
PRINTED DISCLOSURE ABOUT WHERE
TO FILE A COMPLAINT WITH THEIR
THERAPIST SHOULD THE NEED ARISE
THE BILL WAS AMENDED IN THE
SENATE TO MAKE TECHNICAL
CHANGES AND TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION BOTH THE LICENSED
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST
ACT AS WELL AS THECLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKER PRACTICE ACT.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS. I THINK HEROES
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE IN THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALONG MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM THIRTY FIVE A. B.
SIX FIVE THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FIFTY
THREE BY FAMILY MEMBER BLOOM
AND OTHERS AND EXPLAIN ARMORIES
MISTER BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I'M HERE PRESENTING A. B. SIX
FIFTY THREE. IT'S HERE ON
CONCURRENCE IN THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE SENATE OUR
TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING IN
NATURE. THE MEASURE AUTHORIZES
THE DIRECTOR OF GENERAL
SERVICES WITH THE APPROVAL OF
THE ADJUTANT GENERAL. TO LEASE
A PORTION OF THE WEST LOS
ANGELES ARMORY PARKING LOT THAT
IS. NOT USED FOR MILITARY
PURPOSES. AT LEAST WOULD BE THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES TO BILL
THE YEAR ROUND BRIDGE HOUSING
PROGRAM SOMETHING THAT IS IN
EXTREMELY SHORT SUPPLY. IN IN
MY AREA. THIS BILL HAS HAD NO
OPPOSITION IT'S HAD BI PARTISAN
SUPPORT. AND I'M QUITE
CONFIDENT THAT EVEN AUDITOR'S
NAMED POTTER. WOULD SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU MISTER
BLOOM SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS MODE YOU DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM THIRTY SIX AB SIX
EIGHTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ
A SOME PEOPLE SIX EIGHTY NINE
BY SOMETHING MEMBER MCCARTY AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO THE
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT ACT.
MR MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU THIS IS AB SIX EIGHT
NINE BACK ON CONCURRENCE IT'S A
BIPARTISAN MEASURE RELATE TO
OUR LOCAL MUNICIPAL UTILITY
DISTRICTS MOD ALLOWING THEM. TO
PARTNER WITH TECHNOLOGY
COMPANIES WITH LIMITED NON
STOCK EQUITY AGREEMENTS WITH
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS BACK FROM
THE SENATE ASK YOUR ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. WHERE WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY FIVE NEW
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEM
THIRTY SEVEN FILE ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT AB SEVEN FOURTEEN THE
CLERK WILL READ AS A LEGAL
SEVEN FOURTEEN BY FAMILY MEMBER
WOULD ACKLAND HEALING ARTS TO
CLING THE URGENCY THERE UP TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY MISTER
WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
SEVEN FOURTEEN IS A FOLLOW UP
BILL TO AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
OF LAST YEAR THAT REQUIRES
PRESCRIBERS TO OFFER A CO
PRESCRIPTION. OF NALOXONE OR
ANOTHER FDA APPROVED OPIOID
OVERDOSE REVERSAL DRUG WHENEVER
THEY OFFER AN OPIOID FOR BANDS
OF THAT DIE AS A PAIN
PRESCRIPTION TO SPECIFIC
CATEGORIES OF AT RISK PATIENTS
AB SEVEN FOURTEEN WAS AMENDED
IN THE SENATE TO ALSO PROVIDE
AN EXEMPTION FOR VETERINARIANS
AS THE BILL WAS NEVER MEANT TO
APPLY TO VETERINARIANS AB SEVEN
FOURTEEN IS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AS IT NOT. RECEIVED A
SINGLE SINGLE NO VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I BO.
THANK YOU MISTER WOULD SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN
KNOWS THERE ON THE URGENCY AYE
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE BILL
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. BY LETTING THIRTY NINE AB
EIGHT OH NINE THE CLERK WILL
READ. AS A LEGAL EIGHT OH NINE
BY SOME REMEMBER SANTIAGO AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION. MR
SANTIAGO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MINUTES SPEAKER AB.
EIGHT OR NINE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AFTER ACCEPTING
SMALL NONTECHNICAL AMENDMENTS I
THANK YOU RESPECT LAST NIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER SANTIAGO
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ON
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. WORK WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM FORTY
EIGHTY EIGHT SEVENTY TWO THE
CLERK WILL READ AS A LEGAL
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
ACTUALLY TO TAXATION TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB EIGHT SEVEN TWO IS
BACK ON COULD CURRENTS WITH
AMENDMENTS THAT REMOVE THE
RETROACTIVE. PROVISIONS THIS
BILL HELPS CHILDREN ON SMALL
FAMILY FARMS STAY IN THEIR HOME
AFTER THE DEATH OF A PARENT
MOVING FORWARD AB EIGHT SEVEN
TWO CORRECTION IN EQUITY IN THE
LAW TO PROTECT SMALL FARMS AND
AGRICULTURAL OPEN SPACE THIS IS
A NARAL BILL THAT HAS NO NO
VOTES IN BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
SEEING. AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I SIXTY
SEVEN KNOWS ONE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM FORTY ONE EIGHTY NINE
FIFTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ.
THE LABEL NINE FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DEEP IN OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TELECOMMUNICATIONS
MISTER DEEP YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB FIVE
NINETY SIX IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS WERE
TAKING IN THE SENATE TO EXPAND
TESTING TO ALL. NINE ONE ONE
TECHNOLOGY AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER DEEP SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY FOUR KNOWS
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. LOVE LOVE THE VANILLA FILE
ITEM FORTY TWO AB NINE EIGHTY
FOR THE CLERK WILL READ
SOMETHING WILL NINE EIGHTY FOUR
BY SOMETHING MEMBER LACKEY AND
OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO TAXATION
MAKING APPROPRIATION THEREFORE.
MEMBERS MR LACKEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
EIGHTY FOUR IS BACK ON. ORANGE
IT CREATES A VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTION FUND TO PROVIDE
MORE SUICIDE PREVENTION
RESOURCES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
LAST YEAR OVER FORTY THREE
HUNDRED. PEOPLE COMMITTED
SUICIDE WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
ON THIS A VALUABLE MEMBER OF
MEASURE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER LACKEY SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING VOTE I SEVENTY NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM FORTY THREE AB TEN
OH NINE THE CLERK WILL READ AS
A LEGAL TEN OH NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL AND
ACTUALLY TO FIREARMS MR GABRIEL
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I AM PLEASED
TODAY 2% AB TEN OH NINE WHICH
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE. THE
BILL MODERNIZES THE STATE'S
FIREARM REGISTRATION PROCESS
SAVES TAXPAYER RESOURCES AND
INSURED LAWS FORSMAN HAS ACCESS
TO ACCURATE AND RELIABLE GUN
REGISTRATION DATA THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE
ADDRESS CHAPTER IN YOUR SHOES
AND ALLOW FOR THE CONTINUED
REGISTRATION OF CERTAIN
FIREARMS TO BE ABOUT THE MAIL
IN ONLINE REGISTRATION PROCESS.
THIS BILL RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MR GABRIEL
SEEING. AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROOM. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS VERY VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
FORTY FOUR AB TEN SEVENTEEN THE
CLERK WILL READ AS A LEVEL TEN
SEVENTEEN BY SOMETHING MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE RAILRO. THIS
BURKE BACK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
YES COLLEAGUES AB TEN SEVENTEEN
TO IMPROVE THE SAFETY OF
PEDESTRIAN RAILROAD CROSSINGS.
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE FROM THE
SENATE CINNAMON MINTS INCLUDE
AND SIMPLY ADD CO AUTHORS. THE
BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER.
THANK YOU MISS BOERNER HORVATH
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE I SEVENTY NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE AB TEN
SIXTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY WILL TEN SIXTY FIVE BY
THE ONLY MEMBER BERMAN AND
EXPLAIN TO INSURANCE MR BERMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES AB
TEN SIXTY FIVE WOULD MAKE
PERMANENT THE ABILITY OF
INSURERS TO OFFER CONSUMERS THE
OPTION. OF RECEIVING CERTAIN
DOCUMENTS ELECTRONICALLY THE
ADVANTAGES OF OPTIONAL
ELECTRONIC TRANSACTIONS ARE
NUMEROUS INCLUDING FASTER
DELIVERY REDUCED COST
PORTABILITY IN THE AFTERMATH OF
A DISASTER THE ABILITY FOR
CONSUMERS WHO HAVE SUFFERED
LOSSES TO CONDUCT TRANSACTIONS
ELECTRONICALLY AND ACCELERATE
THE RECOVERY PROCESS. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ADDED ADDITIONAL
ADMINISTRATIVE ENFORCEMENT
TOOLS AND REPORT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON CAN
CURRENTS AND SEVEN AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLLING TALLY THE
VOTE I SEVENTY NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM FORTY SIX AB TEN
NINETY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ
AS A LEGAL TEN NINETY NINE BY
FAMILY MEMBER CALDERON AND I
CLING TO INSURANCE MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB TEN
NINE NINE IS DOCTOR CURRENT TO
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE REQUIRE
INSURANCE COMPANIES TO REPORT
TO THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
THEIR- COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
INVESTMENT HOLDINGS IN
CALIFORNIA FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN
TO TWENTY TWENTY. AND EXTENDS A
SUNSET OF THE COIN ADVISORY
BOARD TO JOHNNY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY NINE THERE'S NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE IN SENTIMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON
SEEING. AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRED
OF THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
FORTY SEVEN AB TWELVE NINETY
FOUR THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
LEVEL TWELVE NINETY FOUR BY
SOMEONE NUMBER SALAS AND OTHERS
AND ACT LIKE A CRIMINAL
PROFITEERING. STIR SALAS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE NINETY FOUR THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS WERE TECHNICAL FOLKS
THE BILL'S LANGUAGE SOLELY. ON
ILLEGAL GAMBLING. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR I HAVE A. THANK YOU
MISTER SALAS SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THEROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. HOME MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
LOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE
I SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS ZEROS
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT AB
FOURTEEN FOURTEEN THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME LEGAL FOURTEEN
FOURTEEN BY SOME REMEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND ACTUALLY THE WATER
STREAMING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AMENDMENTS MADE TO AB
FOURTEEN FOURTEEN AND THE
SENATE WERE TECHNICAL IN NATURE
AND BROUGHT ON THE SUPPORT OF
BOTH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES. AND
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL THE BILL HAS RECEIVED
NO NO VOTES AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTES ON CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU MS FREEDMAN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY VOTE I SIXTY NINE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONFERRED IN FILE ITEM FORTY
NINE AB TWO NINETY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ. AS LEGAL TO
NINETY FIVE BY FAMILY MEMBER
DALY AND OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO
INSURANCE IS YOUR DAILY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS BILL
ADDRESSES ACCOUNTING RULES FOR
UNDER WRITTEN TITLE COMPANIES
IT CHANGES THE FORMULA FOR
DETERMINING. WORKING CAPITAL
FOR UNDER WRITTEN TITLE
COMPANIES IN IT RAISES AN UNDER
WRITTEN TITLE COMPANIES MINIMUM
WORKING CAPITAL REQUIREMENT TO
AT LEAST TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. THE BILL IS NECESSARY
BECAUSE A NEW STANDARD THAT WAS
RECENTLY ADOPTED NATIONALLY. BY
THE FINANCIAL ACCOUNTING
STANDARDS BOARD COULD RESULT IN
INCREASED COSTS FOR REAL
PROPERTY TRANSACTIONS INCLUDING
HOME PURCHASES. THE PURCHASE OF
A NEW HOME OR AN EXISTING HOME
THE CHANGES ENACTED BY THIS
BILL WILL AVOID THIS NEGATIVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I
VOTE FOR CONCURRENCE. THANK YOU
MISTER DALY SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELLING
VOTE I SIXTY EIGHT NEWS ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEMS FIFTY FOUR THREE
SIXTY SIX SO WE'D HAVE TO
RETAIN FILE ITEM SIXTY EIGHT
THROUGH SEVENTY FIVE WILL BE
PASSED THE ROUTINES. MOVING TO
FILE ITEM SEVENTY SIX SB SIX
FORTY ONE THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL SIX FORTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY FAMILY MEMBER
BERMAN MR BERMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I RISE
TODAY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDING SB SIX FORTY ONE THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL IN
RESULT CHAPTER OUT CONFLICTS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THE AMENDMENTS AND THAT THE
BILL GO OUT TO. BE PUT BACK ON
THE FILE. WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR SAY
AYE. OPPOSED SAY NO. AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT IN
BACK TO FILE. FILE ITEM SEVENTY
SEVEN THROUGH EIGHTY SIX WILL
BE PASSED ENTERTAINS FILE ITEM
EIGHTY SEVEN SB THREE NINETY
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY THREE
WITH THE MEMONS BY SOME A
MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA. MR
GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS. GOOD
MORNING A COLLEAGUES IN PRISON
IN SB THREE NINETY THREE
AMENDMENTS WHICH WOULD REMOVE
OPPOSITION BY RELEASING THE
MARINO OWNERS FROM LIABILITY
FOR DAMAGE THAT MAY OCCUR TO A
BOAT THAT HAS BEEN IMPOUNDED
EXCEPT FOR GROSS NEGLIGENCE OR
WILLFUL. WANTON MISCONDUCT THAT
RESPECT AS TRAVEL. YOU OUT
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE. OPPOSED
SAY NO. THE AMENDMENTS ADOPTED
OUT TO PRINT IN BACK TO FILE
WILL PASS AND RETAIN AND FILE
ITEMS EIGHTY EIGHT THROUGH
NINETY SEVEN FILE ITEM NINETY
EIGHT. SB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT
.
COULD YOU TO. YEAH WE ARE GOING
TO PASS AND RETAIN AND FILE
ITEM NINETY EIGHT. IRVING
BACKED UP TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY
TWO SB THREE NINETY FOUR THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
THREE NINETY FOUR WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOMETHING NEVER
WICKS. MISS WEEKS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR PURPOSE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU I RISE TO
PRESENT AMENDMENTS FOR SB THREE
NINETY FOUR WHICH CREATES A
DIVERSION PROGRAM FOR PEOPLE
WITH DEPENDENT CHILDREN. THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL ONE CLARIFY
THAT THE DIVERSION PROGRAM
SHOULD NOT BE MORE THAN TWENTY
FOUR MONTHS TO TIGHTEN THE
DEFINITION OF A CARE GIVER
ELIGIBILITY FOR DIVERSION THREE
MAKE PEOPLE AN ELIGIBLE FOR
DIVERSION IF THEY'LL IF THE
ALLEGED CRIMES AGAINST THEIR
DEPENDENT. AND LASTLY ADD OTHER
MINOR TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
THESE AMENDMENTS WILL HELP
REMOVE SOME OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS REX SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER WITHOUT OBJECTION
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS. ALL IN FAVOR SAY
AYE. ALL OPPOSED SAY NO. MAN
MAN SIR ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT IN
BACK TO FILE. FILE ITEM ONE OH
THREE. SB SIX EIGHTY ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL SIX
EIGHTY ONE WITH AMENDMENTS BY
FAMILY MEMBER CALLED AROUND.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS MA'AM IS AN URGENCY
CLAWS AND ASKED THAT THE BILL
GO OUT TO PRINT TO BE PLACED
BACK ON FILE. THANK YOU MISTER
CALDERON SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE. OPPOSED
SAY NO. THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT AND BACK
TO FILE. FILE ITEM ONE OH EIGHT
AS. FILE ITEM ONE AWAY WILL BE
PASSING RETAINED. FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY THREE SB THREE OH SIX
THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
THREE OF SIX WITH AMENDMENTS BY
FAMILY MEMBER OBERNOLTE MISTER
OBERNOLTE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
MORALITY SB THREE TO SB THREE
OH SIX THIS BILL CREATES A PATH
WHERE BY THE TRUSTEE TO REAL
PROPERTY IN CALIFORNIA MAY
RESIGN AND THEIR POSITION OF
TRUSTEE THESE AMENDMENTS. OUR
TECHNICAL AND NON SUBSTANTIVE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
AMENDMENT BE ADOPTED THE BILL
BE SENT OUT TO PRINT AND PUT
BACK ON THE FILE. THANK YOU
MISTER OBERNOLTE SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER WITHOUT OBJECTION
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR SAY
AYE. OPPOSED SAY NO AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT AND
BACK TO FIVE
. FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY EIGHT SB SIX EIGHTY SEVEN
THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL SIX EIGHTY SEVEN WITH THE
MINUTES BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GABRIEL. MR GABRIEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS ON SB SIX EIGHT
SEVEN TODAY ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR RUBIO THEY REQUIRE THE
GOVERNOR TO APPOINT A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM EITHER
THAT. CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES YOU SEE OR CSU SYSTEMS
TO THE HOMELESS COORDINATING
AND FINANCING COUNTY COUNCIL
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR GABRIEL
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. OPPOSED SAY NO.
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED OUT TO
PRINT IN BACK TO FILE
. MOVING
TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY SEVEN SB
SIX SEVENTY NINE THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY
NINE WITH THE MINUTES BASED ON
THE NUMBER PATTERSON MISTER
PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS.
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AMENDMENTS FOR SB SIX
SEVEN NINE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
BATES. THESE AMENDMENTS SIMPLY
ADDRESS CHAPTER IN OUT ISSUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
PATTERSON SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE
A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR SAY
AYE. OPPOSED SAY NO. MAN MAN
SIR ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT AND
BACK TO FILE
. FILE WILL PASS
RETAIN AND FILE ITEMS NINETY
NINE AND ONE HUNDRED FILE ITEM
ONE NO ONE SB FIVE FORTY THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
FIVE FORTY BY SENATOR JONES AND
ACTUALLY TO NONPROFIT
CORPORATIONS MR COOLEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. COLLEAGUES AND
PLEASE RESENT SB FIVE FORTY BY
SENATOR JONES MY FORMER ETHICS
CO CHAIR. COLLEAGUES UNDER
CALIFORNIA CORPORATIONS CODE WE
REGULATE. THE CONDUCT OF
NONPROFIT PUBLIC BUSINESS
CORPORATIONS. THEY'RE THE TYPE
OF IN IS THEIR CONDUCT OF THEIR
AFFAIRS IS AFFECT WITH THE
PUBLIC INTEREST. IN CERTAIN
RESPECTS WE EVEN HAVE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OVERSEEING
COMPENSATION ARRANGEMENTS AND
OF. BECAUSE HERE AFFECT WITH
THE PUBLIC INTEREST THIS BILL
SIMPLY MAKES A SMALL ADJUSTMENT
IN THE LAW RELATING TO THE
PURCHASE OF LIFE INSURANCE ON
BEHALF OF AN OFFICER OF A
PUBLIC BENEFIT CORPORATION. IT
INCREASES THE TOOLS IN THE TOOL
KITS FOR THESE ENTITIES TO
ATTRACT RETAIN OUTSTANDING
TALENT TO WORK ON NEEDED ISSUES
IN OUR STATE IT'S A GOOD VOTE.
GOOD BILL LARGER RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER COOLEY SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
NINE KNOWS ONE MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY SB TWO
THIRTY TO THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOMETHING ABOUT
PERSONAL GARCIA GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YES GOOD MORNING
AMENDMENTS ON SB THE TWO THIRTY
TO AT A SENSE THAT A JARRING
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TO THE
BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER CS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. OPPOSED SAY NO.
MAN MANSARD OPTED OUT TO PRINT
AND BACK TO FILE. FILE ITEM ONE
TO PASS AND RETAIN MOVING TO
FILE ITEM ONE FOR SB FIVE
EIGHTY SIX KERKORIAN SIMPLE
FIVE EIGHTY SIX MY SENATOR ROTH
AND ACTUALLY COMMUNITY COLLEGES
MR HOLDEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
SB FIVE EIGHTY SIX RESPONSE TO
CONCERNS RAISED AT THE SENATE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING BY THE
CAREER TECHNOLOGY AND THE NEW
ECONOMY SELECT COMMITTEE WERE
SEVERAL STAKEHOLDERS RAISE
CONCERNS OVER THE GROWING NEED
FOR SKILLED LABOR TO MEET LOCAL
INDUSTRY EMPLOYMENT GROWTH. MY
PREVIOUS BILL ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT ESTABLISHED THE
COLLEGE AND CAREER ACCESS
PATHWAY OR SEE CAP. THAT
AUTHORIZES COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IN SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO PARTNER
TOGETHER AND OFFERING SEAMLESS
DUAL ENROLLMENT PATHWAY FOR
STUDENTS WHO ARE
UNDERREPRESENTED IN HIGHER
EDUCATION. SB FIVE EIGHTY SIX
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
LOCAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD'S TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AS THEY
DEVELOP THEIR SEE CAP I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EUROPE.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN BEING
IN HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS GO TO
DESERVE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I'M
REFERRING ITEM NUMBER ONE FORTY
EIGHT SB SIX EIGHTY SEVEN MISS
RUBIO TO THE HOUSING COMMITTEE.
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE. MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE OH FIVE S. C. R. TWENTY ONE
THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TWENTY
ONE BY SENATOR BATES AND OTHERS
A BILL TO THE COSTA MESA FIRE
CAPTAIN MICHAEL CREASON
MEMORIAL HIGHWAY MR BRO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE RESENT SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TWENTY
ONE. BY CENTER BATES AND CENTER
MORLOCK DESIGNATING STATE ROUTE
FIFTY FIVE FROM THE NINETEENTH
STREET TO MACARTHUR BOULEVARD
AS THE COSTA MESA FIRE CAPTAIN
MICHAEL KRESNA MEMORIAL
HIGHWAY. CAPTAIN BECAUSE IT WAS
DISTINGUISHED CALIFORNIA
FIREFIGHTER AND MUCH LOVE
FAMILY MAN HIS CHARACTER
INTEGRITY AND COMMITMENT TO THE
COSTA MESA FIRE AND RESCUE
EARNED HIM THE RESPECT AND
ADMIRATION HIS FELLOW
FIREFIGHTERS. AND COUNTLESS
INDIVIDUALS WHOSE LIVES HE
TOUCHED FOLLOWING IN THE
FOOTSTEPS OF HIS FATHER WHO WAS
A POLICE OFFICER CAPTAIN KRESNA
SOUGHT OUT A CAREER IN PUBLIC
SAFETY. PRIOR TO BEING HIRED BY
COSTA MESA IN TWO THOUSAND HE
WORKED AS AN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT TECHNICIAN IN
SEATTLE A PARAMEDIC IN LAS
VEGAS AND A BIG BEAR FIRE
DEPARTMENT FIREFIGHTER.
THROUGHOUT HIS REPUTABLE
EIGHTEEN YEAR TENURE WITH COSTA
MESA CAPTAIN PRESENT WAS A DE
DEDICATED ENGAGE MEMBER THE
DEPARTMENT'S CLOSE KNIT
FIREFIGHTING COMMUNITY. CAPTAIN
KRESNA WAS IN AND SPIRALING
ROLE MODEL FROM HIS PURSUIT AND
LOVER BEING ACCOMPLISHED
IRONMAN ATHLETE A DEDICATED
FIREFIGHTER AND HUSBAND AND
LOOKING FATHER ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE ON AS YOU ARE TWENTY ONE
TO MEMORIALIZE. CAPTAIN CHRISS
MEMORY ON THE FIFTY FIVE
FREEWAY. THANK YOU ZERO MISS
PETRIE-NORRIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. C. R. TWENTY ONE
TO HONOR THE LIFE AND WORK
COSTA MESA FIRE CAPTAIN MICHAEL
CREE SIDE I AM PROUD TO JOIN MY
COLLEAGUE FROM DANA POINT TO
SERVE AS A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR
FOR THIS MEASURE. TAP INCREASE
THAT WAS AN EIGHTEEN YEAR
VETERAN OF THE COSTA MESA OUR
DEPARTMENT HE WAS IN THE STEAM
TO LEADER AND ROLE MODEL. IN
THE DEPARTMENT AND ALL ACROSS
OUR COMMUNITY HE WAS A
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANT. A
DEVOTED FATHER A LEVINE
HUSBANDS. HE WAS IMMENSELY LEFT
BY OUR ENTIRE COMMUNITY AND THE
COMMUNITY WAS STRUCK TO THE
CORE BY HIS SUDDEN AND TRAGIC
LOSS. I ASK ALL OF YOU TO JOIN
ME TO ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA
HONORS AND RECOGNIZES ONE OF
OUR HEROES BY ESTABLISHING THE
COSTA MESA FIRE CAPTAIN MICHAEL
CREASE AT MEMORIAL HIGHWAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS PEACHTREE
NORRIS MR BRO YOU MAKE SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
MISTER VERY MAKE US JUST
RESPECT LAST YEAR ON THE- KIRK
WELL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY NINE KNOWS ZERO
THIS MEASURE PASSES. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. WILL
PASS A RETAIN AND FILE ITEM ONE
OH SIX FILE ITEM ONE OH SEVEN
SB TWENTY THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL TWENTY BY SENATOR
DODD AND OTHERS AND THAT'S WHEN
THE SURPLUS STATE PROPERTY
MAKING APPROPRIATION THEREFORE.
THIS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED GOOD MORNING MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS SB TWENTY WILL
ALLOW NAPA COUNTY TO NEGOTIATE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES TO BY THE EIGHT
HUNDRED FIFTY ACRE SKYLINE
WILDERNESS PARK. ENSURING THAT
THIS PRIME PARK PLAN WITH
POPULAR HIKING TRAILS AND VIEWS
OF THE BAY AREA REMAINS A
PUBLIC PARK IN PERPETUITY.
SKYLINE PARK IS NOT ONLY A
VALUABLE PUBLIC RESOURCE FOR
RECREATION BUT ALSO SERVES TO
PRESERVE A PRISTINE WATERSHED
AND RICH WILDLIFE HABITAT. SB
TWENTY ALLOWS THE STATE TO SELL
OR EXCHANGE AT FAIR MARKET
VALUE SKYLINE PARK TO THE
COUNTY OR TO THE CAT NAPA
COUNTY REGIONAL PARK IN OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT. TO ENSURE ITS
CONTINUED PRESERVATION THERE
WAS NO OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
THEIR CURRY. SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. I
MEMBERS VOTED DESIRED OF THE-
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THIS.
MEASURE PASSES. WILL PASS THE
ROUTINE ON FILE ITEMS ONE OH
EIGHT THROUGH ONE TEN. FILE
ITEM ONE ELEVEN SB ONE TWENTY
EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL ONE TWENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR PELL AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC CONTRACTS
IT'S GONZALEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU I RISE TO
PRESENT SB ONE TWENTY EIGHT
WHICH WOULD EXTEND THE SUNSET
AND EXISTING BEST VALUE
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTING
PROGRAM. FOR AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
YEARS THE BEST VALUE METHOD
TAKES INTO CONSIDERATION OTHER
FACTORS INCLUDING LABOR
COMPLIANCE AND SAFETY RECORD IN
ORDER TO EVALUATE RATE
CONTRACTORS QUALIFICATIONS AND
ABILITY TO CARRY OUT THE WORK
AS AT THE BEST PRICE POSSIBLE.
THIS BILL WILL ALSO ADD THE
COUNTIES OF MONTEREY AND SOUND
CLEAR TO THE PILOT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ SEEING
AND HEARING NO FOR THE DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES WILL
PASS AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS
ONE TWELVE THIRTY ONE NINETEEN
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY SB TWO
FORTY THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY BY
SENATOR DODD NATIONALLY TO
INSURANCE DECLARING THE URGENCY
THERE UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SIR DALY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. THIS BILL ADDRESSES
ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED DURING
A JOINT HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
AND SENATE INSURANCE
COMMITTEES. HELD THE LAST YEAR.
IT REQUIRES UNLICENSED
ADJUSTERS TO UNDERGO TRAINING
RELEVANT TO ADJUSTING CLAIMS IN
OUR STATE THE BILL ALSO
REQUIRES INSURERS TO PROVIDE
CLAIMANTS WITH THE PRIMARY
POINT OF CONTACT. IF THE CLAIM
IS REASSIGNED TO THREE
DIFFERENT ADJUSTERS WITHIN A
SIX MONTH PERIOD THE BILL HAS
RECEIVED NARY A NO VOTE AND HAS
NO OPPOSITION. IT'S SENATOR
DODD'S BILL I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER DALYSEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FIVE
NEWS HERE ON THE URGENCY AYE
AYES SIXTY FIVE NEWS HERE ON
THE BILL THIS MEASURE PASSES
WILL PASS THIRTEEN AND FILE
ITEMS ONE TWENTY ONE AND ONE
TWENTY TWO MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY FOUR SB THREE FORTY
THREE THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY THREE
BY SENATOR PAN AND ACTUALLY TO
HEALTH CARE. MISTER KALRA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS SENATE BILL
THREE FORTY THREE REMOVES
PROVISIONS A LAW THAT ALLOWS
KAISER PERMANENTE TO REPORT
LESS INFORMATION TO REGULATORS
THAN OTHER HEALTH PLANS AND
HOSPITALS. CURRENCY LAWS LIKE
RATE REVIEW AND HOSPITAL
FINANCIAL DISCLOSURES WERE
CREATED TO HELP PURCHASERS AND
REGULATORS MONITOR ACOSTA DRIVE
HEALTH INSURANCE PREMIUM RATES.
AS HEALTHCARE COSTS CONTINUE TO
RISE POLICYMAKERS PURCHASERS
AND CONSUMERS HAVE ACCESS TO
THE SAME INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
IS DRIVING COST INCREASES AT
KAISER AS THEY HAVE ABOUT EVERY
OTHER HOSPITAL AND HEALTH PLAN.
IN ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
THE AUTHOR AGREED TO AMENDMENTS
TO ADDRESS SOME OF KAISER'S
CONCERNS AND REINSTATED THE
KEYSERLING WAS TO ALLOW THEM TO
REPORT BOUNCE SHEETS AND CASH
FLOW STATEMENTS AS A GROUP. ALL
PARTIES AGREE THAT THERE'S
NOTHING IN THIS BILL THAT
KAISER IS UNABLE TO COMPLY WITH
WITH THAT I RESPECT WE ASK AND
I BOTH. THANK YOU MISTER KALRA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY
EIGHT KNOWS TWELVE THIS MEASURE
PASSES WILL PASS AND RETAIN AND
FILE ITEMS. ONE TWENTY FIVE TO
ONE THIRTY ONE FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY TWO SB FOUR THIRTEEN.
THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL FOUR THIRTEEN BY SENATOR
RUBIO AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE SAN GABRIEL WATER QUALITY
AUTHORITY. MR CHOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER TODAY IMPRISONING
SP FOUR THIRTEEN A DISTRICT
SPECIFIC BILL THAT WOULD MODIFY
THE ELECTION SCHEDULE FOR THE
SAN GABRIEL BASIN WATER QUALITY
AUTHORITY. AND CONSOLIDATE
DUPLICATIVE REPORTS BY CUTTING
DOWN ON A NUMBER OF SPECIAL
ELECTIONS AND REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF REPORTS THAT MUST BE
PREPARED THIS BILL SAVES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TIME AND TAXPAYERS
MONEY. SB FOUR THIRTEEN IS
SPONSORED BY THE SINK ABLE
BASIN WATER QUALITY AUTHORITY
IT HAS NO OPPOSITION AND PASSED
OUT OF ALL ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES
WOULD UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAO SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL LOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY FIVE NEWS ONE THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WILL MOVE BACK
UP TO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY ONE
SB FOUR HUNDRED THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL FOUR HUNDRED
BY SENATOR UMBERG AND ACTUALLY
TO BE A KILLER AIR POLLUTION.
THIRTEEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER SB FOUR
HUNDRED GIVES LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS WHO REPLACING OLD
POLLUTING CAR UNDER CLEAN CARS
FOR ALL. MORE OPTIONS THE BILL
ADDS ELECTRIC BIKES AND
ELECTRIC BICYCLE RIDE SHARING
AS TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS THEY
CAN CHOOSE FROM THE BILL HAS NO
NO VOTES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
DR. THANK YOU MISTER KING
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES. PASS A ROUTINE
AND FILE ITEMS ONE THIRTY THREE
AND ONE THIRTY FOUR FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY FIVE SB FIVE THIRTY
FOR THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE
BILL FIVE THIRTY FOUR BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AND ACTUALLY
TO INSURANCE MR DAILY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER SENATOR BRADFORD'S BILL
HAS THREE COMPONENTS FIRST IT
REESTABLISHES THE INSURANCE
SUPPLIER DIVERSITY SURVEY. IT
ALSO CODIFIES THE GOVERNING
BOARD DIVERSITY SURVEY WHICH IS
DESIGNED TO IMPROVE DIVERSITY
AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF
GOVERNANCE IN THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY. LASTLY IT CODIFIES
THE INSURANCE DIVERSITY TASK
FORCE WHICH PROVIDES
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE ON HOW
TO BEST ACHIEVE ITS DIVERSITY
GOALS. THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MISTER DALY. SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. HOME MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY SIX KNOWS
THREE THIS MEASURE PASSES. FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY SIX SB FIVE
FORTY THREE THE CLERK WILL READ
BY FORTY THREE BY SENATOR PAN
AND ACTUALLY THE VEHICLES. WE
ARE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY SIX. WE
WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY SIX SB SIX SEVEN SEVEN
THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
SIX SEVENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
ALLEN AND ACTUALLY THE FOOD
SAFETY. THANK YOU ARE CURRY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS SB SIX SEVEN
SEVEN BY SENATOR ALLEN
PROHIBITS THE USE OF NATURAL
LATEX GLOVES IN RESTAURANTS AND
OTHER FOOD FACILITIES. THIS IS
A SEEMINGLY SIMPLE BILL BUT IT
HAS LIFE CHANGING SIGNIFICANCE
FOR THOSE AFFECTED. THE MORE A
PERSON BECAUSE IT COMES INTO
CONTACT WITH LATEX THE GREATER
THE RISK OF BECOMING ALLERGIC
FOR THIS REASON WORKERS WHO
MUST REGULARLY USE LATEX GLOVES
ARE AT A HIGHER RISK FOR
DEVELOPING A LIFE THREATENING
LATEX ALLERGY. MANY RESTAURANTS
HAVE ALREADY GONE LATEX FREE
AND HAVE MANY HEALTH CARE AND
DENTAL FACILITIES THAT WANT TO
PROTECT THEIR STAFF.
PROHIBITING LATEX IS AN EASY
WAY TO OFFER THOSE WITH AN
ALLERGY SOME PEACE OF MIND AND
SAFETY ALSO HELPING TO LIMIT
NEEDLESS EXPOSURE EXPOSURE TO
RISKS TO STAFF. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGH THE PRO THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
AGUIAR-CURRY SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. QUIRK
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE EYES FIFTY EIGHT NO
ZEROS MEASURE PASSES. WE WILL
PASS AND RETAIN AND FILE ITEMS
ONE FORTY NINE AND ONE FIFTY
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY ONE SB
SEVEN FORTY THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN FORTY BY
SENATOR MITCHELL AND I PLAN TO
INSURANCE MR MAYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THE MENACE WEAKER
ARISE RESENT SB SEVEN FORTY THE
RESULT OF A YEARS LONG
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT BETWEEN
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONERS AND SEVERAL STATE
CONTROLLER'S OFFICES. IN TWENTY
ELEVEN STATES TERMINATE LIFE
INSURERS WERE NOT DISTURBING
LIFE INSURANCE PAYMENTS WHEN
THE OWNERS OR BENEFICIARIES DID
NOT FATHER INSURANCE CLAIMS. SB
SEVEN FORTY CODIFIES RESULTING
SETTLEMENT AGREED TO BY NEARLY
FORTY INJURES ACROSS THE NATION
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN UNANIMOUS SUPPORT.
AND OPPOSITION RESPECT THE
REQUEST YOUR I HOPE THANK YOU
MISTER MAYES SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY TWO NEWS HERE
THIS MEASURE PASSES WILL PASS A
ROUTINE AND FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
TWO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY THREE
SB SEVEN SEVENTY NINE THE CLERK
WILL READ SENATE BILL SEVEN
SEVENTY NINE BAD COMPANY ON
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER AND
ACTUALLY TO WATER. SIR GARCIA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED SO YOU
BETTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
THE THIS THE BILL IS THE
NATURAL RESOURCES SENATE NOT TO
RESOURCES AND WATER COMMITTEE
BILL WHICH MAKES A MINOR NON
CONTROVERSIAL TECHNICAL CHANGES
TO THE STATUE IMPACTING THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD AND DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
TO THE. MEASURE RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR RIVAL. THANK YOU MR
GARCIA S. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY TWO KNOWS ONE THIS
MEASURE PASSES. PASS AND RETAIN
AND FILE ITEMS ONE FIFTY FOUR
AND ONE FIFTY FIVE. BY LATE ONE
FIFTY SIX SB SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT BY THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION AND ACTUALLY THE
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES CLING THE
URGENCY THERE UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY MR BIGELOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SB SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT IS A G. O.
COMMITTEE BILL WHICH SIMPLY
FIXES. AN UNINTENDED ERROR FROM
LAST YEAR'S AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY TWO IT IS RECEIVE
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER BIGELOW
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NEWS HERE ON
THE URGENCY AYE AYES SIXTY
SEVEN NEWS ZERO ON THE BILL
THIS MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY SEVEN SB SEVEN NINETY
THE CLERK WILL READ. SENATE
BILL SEVEN NINETY BY THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE AND ACTUALLY TAXATION.
BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN CONGRESS
CHANGE THE PROCESS VIA FOR IRS
AUDITING PARTNERSHIPS LAST OF
THE LEGISLATURE AND ACTED AS BE
TWO SEVENTY FOUR GLAZER TO
CONFORM STATE LAWS TO THESE
CHANGES. SB SEVEN NINETY
CLARIFIES ONE AMBIGUITY IN SB
TWO SEVENTY FOUR TO ENSURE THAT
TAX PAYERS CAN MORE EASILY
COMPLY WITH THESE NEW RULES AND
F. T. B. CAN EFFECTIVELY
IMPLEMENT THEM. THE BILL ALSO
MAKES OTHER TECHNICAL AND
CONFORMING CHANGES. THE MEASURE
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION AND
OTHERS AND HAS NO OPPOSITION
AND HAS ENJOYED STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
BOTH. THANK YOU MISS BURKE
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. WORK WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THIS MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
EIGHT WHO HAS TO RETAIN TO FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY NINE S. BEFORE
THIRTY SIX THE CLERK WILL READ
SYMBOL FOR THIRTY SIX MY CENTER
HURTADO AND ACTUALLY THE CHILD
ABUSE THIS RACE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS TODAY PRESENT
TO YOU SB FOUR THIRTY SIX. ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR DONNA BOTH OF
THEM A TECHNICAL BILL WHICH
DEFINES FAMILY RESOURCE CENTERS
IS RECOGNIZED ENTITIES UNDER
STATE LAW TO HELP PREVENT CHILD
ABUSE AND TO FURTHER THE
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
MODELS OF CARE IN CALIFORNIA.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT EARLY
CHILDHOOD ADVERSITIES
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED CHILD'S
DEVELOPMENTAL FUNCTIONING WHICH
INCREASED RISKS OF SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL ACADEMIC.
PSYCHOLOGICAL AND BEHAVIORAL
PROBLEMS. SB FOUR THIRTY SIX
SIXTY FORMALIZE FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTERS IN STATUTE FORMALLY
RECOGNIZING THEIR INVOLVEMENT
TO MITIGATE THESE CHALLENGES
AND PROGRAMMATIC RESOURCE IS
ALREADY UNDER WAY WITHIN THE
OFFICE OF CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION. THE BILL HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
IS CO SPONSORED BY CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION AND CALIFORNIA
RESOURCE ASSOCIATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS RAY S.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. BURKE WELL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY
FOUR KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE
PASSES MOVING BACK UP TO FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY SIX SB FIVE
FORTY THREE THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL FIVE FORTY THREE BY
SENATOR PAN AND ACTUALLY TO
VEHICLES MR MCCARTY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
WE PASSED A LAW THAT SETS
STANDARDS AND UNIFORMITY
ELATION SPUR PEDAL POWER
QUADRICYCLE IN CALIFORNIA YOU
SEE THEM HERE IN SACRAMENTO IN
A FEW CITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
THIS WOULD REMOVE THE SUNSET ON
THIS LAW THESE PEDAL POWER
QUADRICYCLE IS ALSO KNOWN AS
PEDICABS ARE MULTI PASSENGER
BIKE SAID PRIMARILY RELY ON
HUMAN POWER. BUT HAVE AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO'S DRIVING
STEERING NOT PADDLING THIS IS
BEEN A RESPONSIBLE INDUSTRY
LAST YEAR'S CHP SAYS NO
REPORTED ACCIDENTS OR INCIDENTS
WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION AND WE DO
HAVE LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
SUPPORT AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
MCCARTY SEEING AND HEARING. NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY KNOWS HERE
THIS MEASURE PASSES. WE WILL
PASS A ROUTINE AND FILE ITEMS
ONE THIRTY SEVEN THROUGH. ONE
FORTY FIVE. MEMBERS WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO THE SECOND DAY CONSENT
CALENDAR. FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
THERE'S A RESOLUTION ON TODAY'S
CONSENT CALENDAR BEFORE WE VOTE
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR WILL
FIRST TAKE UP THIS RESOLUTION
THAT IS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FOR PURPOSE OF ADDING CO
AUTHORS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE ONE ROLL CALL VOTE
AND ALLOW ANY MEMBER TO ADD ON
AS A CO AUTHOR TO THE
RESOLUTION. THE CLERK WILL READ
THE RESOLUTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. AS ON THE CURRENT
VERSION SIXTY ONE BY SOME
REMEMBER SALAS RELATIVE TO GOLD
STAR MOTHERS AND FAMILIES DAY
HOUSE RESOLUTION FIFTY TWO BY
FAMILY MEMBER LACKEY RELATIVE
TO WE CARD AWARENESS MONTH.
WILL OPEN THE ROLE TO ALLOW
MEMBERS ADAM WHAT THERE IS TO
THIS LIST OF RESOLUTIONS.
MEMBERS THIS VOTE IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. MEMBERS THIS VOTE IS
FOR CO AUTHORS. MEMBERS IF YOU
WISH TO ADD YOUR NAME AS A CO
AUTHOR TO THE RESOLUTION PLEASE
VOTE NOW. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY SIX CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION. THE
CLERK WILL APPLY THAT TO ALL
RESOLUTIONS THAT ARE ON TODAY'S
CONSENT CALENDAR. MOVING TO A
VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
FILE ITEMS ONE FORTY SEVEN
THROUGH. ONE FIFTY EIGHT. FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY FOUR WEPASSED
ENTERTAINED AS ANY MEMBER WHICH
TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING
HEARING NONE THE CLERK WILL
READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR. ASSUMING CURRENT
CURRENT VERSION ONE POINT
FOURTEEN BY SELLING OVER KALRA
AND OTHERS WILL TO DO A HUNDRED
FIFTIETH BIRTHDAY OF MAHATMA
GANDHI. THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE IN THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY EIGHT NO
ZERO. THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED THE CLERK WILL READ
READ THE REMAINING ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SELECT THE
CURRENT VERSION ONE SEVENTEEN I
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO SOMETHING
HER RESOLUTION ONE EIGHTEEN BY
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO NINE ACRE
RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY SIX AYE
AYES SIXTY EIGHT NO. ZERO AND
HOUSE RESOLUTION FIFTY TWO I
SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO. MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS MISS GARCIA DON'T
LEAVE SO QUICKLY OUR FIRST
ANNOUNCEMENT OF THE DAY IS THAT
TODAY IS MISS GARCIA'S BIRTHDAY
HAPPY BIRTHDAY MISS GARCIA.
THIS SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS FRIDAY AUGUST TWENTY
THIRD THERE'S NO FLOOR SESSION
YOU KNOW CHECK IN SESSION
MONDAY AUGUST TWENTY SIX WE
WILL HAVE FLOOR SESSION AT ONE
PM. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
KEEP THE QUORUM CALL FOR OUR
FIRST ADJOURNING MEMORY TODAY.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR
. QUORUM CALL IS NOT
LIFTED WE ARE HOLDING QUORUM
CALL FOR FIRST TO JOIN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MEMBERS THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON
ANY GERMAN MEMORY TODAY MR
GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TODAY
TO ASK THAT WE ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY OF MY GRANDMOTHER
LILLIAN KATZ BURKE. WHO PASSED
AWAY EARLIER THIS MONTH AT THE
AGE OF NINETY FOUR. MY GRANDMA
LILLIAN WAS BORN ON DECEMBER
SEVENTH NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR IN
LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA. SHE
DIRT A DIFFICULT AND
CHALLENGING CHILDHOOD. HER
FAMILY WAS POOR AND SHE LOST
HER OWN MOTHER WHEN SHE WAS
JUST EIGHT YEARS OLD. SHE
EXPERIENCED ILLNESS SEPARATION
POVERTY AND LOSS AT A YOUNG
AGE. GET IT IT WAS THESE
EXPERIENCES THAT HELPED SHAPE A
LONELY IN INTO A WOMAN WHO WAS
RESILIENT WITHOUT PRETENSE AND
FULL FOR SIMPLE PLEASURES THAT
TOO MANY OF US TAKE FOR GRANTED.
AFTER GRADUATING FROM DORSEY
HIGH SCHOOL LILLIAN MOVED TO
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WHERE SHE
WORKED TO SUPPORT THE ALLIED
EFFORT IN WORLD WAR TWO. A TINY
JEWISH VERSION OF ROSIE THE
RIVETER SHE WORKED FIRST AS A
SHIP FITTER IN THE RICHMOND
SHIPYARDS AND LATER JOINED THE
WOMEN'S ARMY CORPS. FOLLOWING
THE WAR LILLIAN USED HER G. I.
BENEFITS TO STUDY AT THE SAN
FRANCISCO CONSERVATORY OF MUSIC
A HIGH POINT IN HER LIFE LONG
LOVE AFFAIR WITH CLASSICAL
MUSIC. SHORTLY AFTER THE WAR MY
GRANDMA MET AND MARRIED MY
GRANDFATHER FRED KATZ BERG OF
BLESSED MEMORY. AS MY MOM
SHARED AT HER FUNERAL ONCE
WILLIAM MET FRED LIFE FINALLY
BECAME A FAIRY TALE WITH A
HAPPY ENDING. MY GRANDPARENTS
MOVED TO WANNA CREEK AND WERE
ACTIVE IN BUILDING A GROWING
COMMUNITY IN THE EAST BACK.
AMONG OTHER INVOLVEMENT LILLIAN
WAS ONE OF THE FOUNDING MEMBERS
OF TEMPLE ISAIAH A REFORM
JEWISH CONGREGATION IN
LAFAYETTE CALIFORNIA. EVEN
THOUGH THEY WERE A YOUNG COUPLE
OF LIMITED MEANS MY
GRANDPARENTS PERSONALLY CO
SIGNED A LOAN SO THAT THE
TEMPLE COULD PURCHASE ITS FIRST
PERMANENT HOME. AND WHAT WAS IT
FORMERLY A POLYNESIAN
RESTAURANT. TEMPLE ISAIAH HAS
SINCE GROWN INTO A STRONG AND
VIBRANT CENTER OF JEWISH LIFE
IN THE DIE APPLE VALLEY. AND IS
AN INTEGRAL PART OF LILLIAN AND
FRED'S LEGACY. TOGETHER WITH MY
GRANDFATHER LILIAN HELPED RAISE
THREE INDEPENDENT STRONG AND
COMPASSIONATE DAUGHTERS EACH OF
WHOM HAS DEDICATED THEIR
CONSIDERABLE TALENTS TO CARING
FOR AND HELPING OTHERS. THROUGH
NURSING TEACHING RESEARCH UNION
ORGANIZING AND SOCIAL ACTIVISM.
LILLIAN WAS EXTREMELY PROUD OF
HER DAUGHTER'S AND HER SIX
GRANDCHILDREN. HER DURING
LEGACY IS A FAMILY THAT IS
DEVOTED TO EACH OTHER AND TO
THE PURSUIT OF SOCIAL JUSTICE
WHAT WE JEWS REFER TO AS DE
KOONING ALARM. MY MEMORIES OF
MY GRANDMA ARE OF A KIND AND
GENEROUS WOMAN WHO APPRECIATED
THE LITTLE THINGS. SHE ENJOYED
MUSIC READING DINNER PARTIES
CARD GAMES AND DESERT. SHE
LOVED CATS AND ANYTHING RELATED
TO CATS PURPLE WHAT'S OUR
SIGNATURE COLOR. SHE WAS DEEPLY
INTERESTED IN POLITICS AND
CURRENT EVENTS AND WAS A
DEVOTED A LIFELONG DEMOCRAT.
SHE ESPECIALLY LOVED OUR FORTY
FOURTH PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA
AND WAS A VIGOROUS DEFENDER OF
HIS POLICIES AND
ACCOMPLISHMENTS. SHE WAS A
GREAT BAKER WHO WAS FAMOUS FOR
HER MOM TO READ. AND SHE HAD A
WONDERFUL LAUGH. IN HER LATER
YEARS LAYIN SUFFERED FROM
DEMENTIA A TERRIBLE DISEASE
THAT SHE WAS INITIALLY ABLE TO
MASK WITH HER INTELLECT.
DESPITE THESE DIFFICULT LATER
YEARS WE WILL REMEMBER MY
GRANDMA LILLIAN FOR HER EASY
GOING MANNER HER LOVE OF
CONVERSATION AND OF COMMUNITY
AND HER COMMITMENT TO FAMILY.
LILIAN KATZ WORKS MEMORY IS A
BLESSING TO OUR FAMILY AND TO
HER COMMUNITY. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURN TODAY
IN HER MEMORY. THANK YOU MR
GABRIEL OUR CONDOLENCES TO YOU
AND YOUR FAMILY YOUR
GRANDMOTHER'S LOSSES A
PARTICULAR MEANING TO MY
COMMUNITY AND SHE HELPED TO
BUILD IT. AND MAY HER MEMORY BE
A BLESSING. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE QUORUM CALL WILL
NOW BE LIFTED AND WE MOVED THE
ADDITIONAL ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR
.
MISS FRIEDMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE TO ASK THE
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN THE
MEMORY OF A MAN CONSIDERED BY
MANY TO BE THE GODFATHER OF
WATER POLICY IN CALIFORNIA.
RAMEN EDGAR CORLEY BORDER
MODESTO IN NINETEEN THIRTY SIX
RAY SERVED IN THE U. S. NAVY IN
THEIR CONSTRUCTION FORCED KNOWN
AS THE SEABEES THAT EXPERIENCE
LED HIM TO A DEGREE IN CIVIL
ENGINEERING FROM CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY LA IN NINETEEN
SIXTY FOUR. HE LATER WENT ON TO
EARN A PUBLIC WORKS MANAGEMENT
CERTIFICATE FROM UCLA AFTER
COLLEGE RESTARTED WITH THE LA
DEPARTMENT OF WATER AND POWER
WE'RE HIS HEAVY CONSTRUCTION
BACKGROUND WAS PUT TO WORK ON
THE TEAM THAT HELPED DESIGN THE
SECOND LA AQUEDUCT. IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE RAY LEFTY W. P.
TO SERVICE A LOBBYIST FOR THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES TEN YEARS
LATER HE JOINED THE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AS OUR LEAD
ADVOCATE IN SACRAMENTO AND
REMAINED WITH M. W. D. FOR
NEARLY TWO DECADES. HE ENGAGE
WITH POLICY MAKERS ON
LEGISLATION REGULATIONS AND
EXECUTIVE ACTIONS THAT COULD
IMPACT THE DISTRICTS WATER
SUPPLIES FROM THE STATE WATER
PROJECT IN THE COLORADO RIVER.
IN ADDITION HE WAS THE NW DIS
LEAD WITH MULTIPLE REGIONAL
STATE AND NATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS. FOLLOWING HIS
TIME AT METROPOLITAN HE WENT ON
TO CONSULT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION. AND FORMALLY
RETIRED FROM THE POLITICAL
SCENE THREE YEARS LATER. RAY IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WATER BY HIS
WIFE DEBBIE HIS TWO SONS BRIAN
AND ERIC CORLEY. HIS DAUGHTER
IN LAW KELLY HAD POORLY AND HIS
FIVE GRANDCHILDREN THAT HE
ADORED. BREANNA MORGAN REAGAN
KENNEDY AND DAVID. RAY WAS AN
INCREDIBLE MAN A MENTOR AND A
LIFELONG FRIEND TO MANY AND OUR
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES CONDOLENCES
GO OUT TO HIS FAMILY AND
FRIENDS. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN MISTER PATTERSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
IN MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND UP MEMBERS OF.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING ME AND
OTHERS FROM FRESNO CALIFORNIA
TO HONOR THE LIFE OF FRESNO
STATE UNIVERSITY POLICE CHIEF
DAVID WHERE TO. MISTER WHERE TO
PASSED AWAY AUGUST SIXTEENTH AT
THE EARLY AGE OF SIXTY EIGHT
AFTER A SHORT BUT SERIOUS
ILLNESS. CHIEF WHERE TO A WAS
DEVOTED TO SERVING AND
PROTECTING THE STUDENTS FACULTY
AND THE STAFF AT FRESNO STATE
HE DID THAT. FOR FIFTEEN YEARS.
PRIOR TO HIS TIME AT FRESNO
STATE. HE WORKED FOR THE FRESNO
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT HE
RETIRED AS A LIEUTENANT. FRESNO
STATE'S PRESIDENT DR JOSEPH
CASTRO CALLED HIM AN EXEMPLARY
LEADER WITH WAIT ON WAVERING
INTEGRITY EVEN UNDER THE MOST
CHALLENGING. OF CIRCUMSTANCES
AND TO ALL THOSE HE SERVED ON
THE CAMPUS AND IN THE COMMUNITY
WE HONOR HIS PASSING AND-
CONCUR WHOLEHEARTEDLY WITH THE
SENTIMENTS OF DR CASTRO. CHIEF
WHERE TO WAS A FRESNO STATE
ALONG THAT HE TAUGHT AT THE
UNIVERSITY HE IS REMEMBERED BY
SO MANY OF HIS COLLEAGUES AS A
VERY KIND. AND NOBLE LEADER.
CHIEF WHERE TO IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE CYNTHIA AND FOR
CHILDREN AND THREE
GRANDCHILDREN. HE IS ALSO
SURVIVED BY HIS FATHER PETE
WHERE TO BROTHER MICHAEL AND
SISTER TO WRESTLE. WE THANK THE
CHIEF FOR HIS SERVICE FOR HIS
LIFE WELL LIVED AND WE ASK YOU
TO JOIN US IN HONORING HIS
MEMORY WITH OUR ADJOURNMENT
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER PATTERSON. MR LACKEY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
IN MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. I RISE TO ADJOURN THE
MEMORY OF LATE O'CONNOR WHO
PASSED AWAY AUGUST SIXTEENTH.
AFTER A LIFETIME OF SERVICE TO
HER COMMUNITY. MISTER CONNOR
WAS BORN IN NEW YORK CITY IN
NINETEEN FORTY ONE. SHE WAS
RAISED IN HOLLYWOOD WITH HER
THREE BROTHERS. SHE MOVED TO
THE ANTELOPE VALLEY IN NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT WHERE SHE
ESTABLISHED HERSELF AS THE
FIRST FEMALE LOAN OFFICER. AND
THE COMPANY THAT YOU WORK FOR.
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING SHE WAS
A TRAILBLAZER. AND SHE WAS
NEVER SATISFIED WITH THE STATUS
QUO. AFTER MAKING A NAME FOR
HERSELF AND HOME LOANS I HAD TO
TURN HER ATTENTION TO A NEW
GROUP OF THE COMMUNITY. THAT
NEEDED A VOICE. ACTIVE MILITARY
PERSONNEL AND THEIR FAMILIES.
SHE STARTED THE EDWARDS AIR
FORCE BASE CIVILIAN MILITARY
SUPPORT GROUP TO ESTABLISH A
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN CIVIC
ON THE BASE
HOLIDAYS PACKING AND DELIVERING
BASKETS OF FOOD TO THOSE
STATION AT EDWARDS AIRFORCE
BASE AND LISTED COUNTLESS
VOLUNTEERS AROUND THE ANALOG
VALLEY TO JOIN IN ON OUR MANY
OUTREACH ACTIVITIES FOR THOSE
DEPLOYED OVERSEAS. IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN MISTER O'CONNOR
WAS AWARDED THE ZACHARY AND
ELIZABETH FISHER DISTINGUISH
CIVILIAN WHO MONETARY AWARD FOR
HER GENEROSITY TOWARDS THE
MILITARY. ANYONE WHO KNEW I
KNEW SHE WAS COMPASSIONATE AND
A LOVING FRIEND. AND RELENTLESS
ADVOCATE FOR THE MILITARY AND
THEIR FAMILIES I'D ALSO WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE AND WAS ONCE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE ADULT VALLEY
BOARD OF TRADE. SHE SHOWED US
HOW TO HAVE A RIVER RESPECT FOR
OUR COUNTRY AND FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO SERVED. MISS O'CONNOR'S
BRIGHT SPIRIT AND A DURING WORK
FOR THE ADULT VALLEY WILL BE
MISSED DEEPLY. AND IS IN HER
MEMORY THAT ASKED WE ADJOURN
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER LACKEY. MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES THE DESK BE
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUESTS TO JOURNEY MEMORY WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WE PASS RETAINED ALL
MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN. MR BONTA
MOVES IN MISTER LACKEY SECOND
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL MONDAY AUGUST TWENTY
SIXTH AT ONE PM
. SB SEVEN SEVEN
NINE NO TO HI. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON VOTE CHANGE SENATE BILL
SEVEN SEVENTY NINE NOTES I.
IRWIN SP FOUR THIRTEEN NO TÁI.
THE CHANGES ONLY NUMBER IRWIN
SENATE BILL FOUR THIRTEEN NO
TÁI. GONZALEZ SB FIVE FORTY
BY JONES FROM I TO KNOW. THE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
SENATE BILL FIVE FORTY I TO
KNOW